Tell us about Singin' In The Bathtub.
These are performances that
are meant for children,
is that right?
Well yes, Sony Wonder
Music they came to me.
Their whole this is great music for kids
that parents can actually
endure, if not enjoy.
And actually this is a fantastic album.
We put together a whole bunch of songs,
almost all of them from
40 and 50 years ago,
great old novelty songs,
kinda thing Danny Kaye and
Cab Calloway used to sing.
Gave them these fabulous
swing arrangements.
Great music producer Jai
Winding did it with me
and voila, I'm a recording artist.
Now what we wanted to
do tonight obviously,
was have you sing one of these songs
for a group of children.
We couldn't get a group of children
so John is now gonna sing these songs.
We have some crew members here.
(audience laughing)
These guys are all union and
you can do this for them?
I'm delighted.
All right let's see this.
I wanna see this right now.
(audience cheering)
I will entertain children of all ages.
Hi kids.
(audience members) Hi.
I said, hi kids.
That's better.
(playing guitar)
♪ I had a rooster and
the rooster pleased me. ♪
♪ I fed my rooster by
the green apple tree. ♪
♪ My old rooster went cocka doodle doo. ♪
♪ Dee doodle-dee
doodle-dee doodle-dee do. ♪
(audience laughs)
♪ I had a piggy and
the piggy pleased me. ♪
♪ I fed my piggy by
the green apple tree. ♪
♪ My old piggy went (oinking) ♪
(audience laughs)
Come on kids.
(oinking)
That's better.
Come on let's hear it.
(oinking)
♪ Well my old rooster
went cocka doodle doo. ♪
♪ Dee doodle-dee doodle-dee doodle-dee. ♪
♪ I had a cow and the cow pleased me. ♪
♪ I fed my cow by the green apple tree. ♪
♪ My old cow went (mooing). ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ My old piggy went (oinking) ♪
♪ My old rooster went cocka doodle doo. ♪
♪ Dee doodle-dee doodle-dee doodle-dee. ♪
♪ I had a horsey and
the horsey pleased me. ♪
♪ I fed my horsey by
the green apple tree. ♪
♪ My old horsey went (neighing). ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ My old cow went (mooing). ♪
Come on let's try it boys.
(mooing)
♪ My old piggy went (oinking). ♪
There ya go.
Everybody sing now.
♪ My old rooster went cocka doodle doo. ♪
♪ Dee doodle-dee
doodle-dee doodle-dee do. ♪
(audience cheering)
How about that!
[Conan] Give it up for John!
[John] Now that's entertainment.